hablamos ahora de economía en directo
américa de france24 y por supuesto está
en nuestra mesa de trabajo daniela
blandón danny qué bueno estar yo de
vuelta porque fui yo el que me fui una
semanita es primero soy yo después nunca
nos vamos a poner daniela con la muerte
de la reina isabel muchos se preguntan a
cuánto ascienden los costos funerarios
mire raúl la muerte de la reina isabel
paralizó de golpe los asuntos de estado
en gran bretaña en un momento en el que
el gobierno el banco de inglaterra
también las empresas y hasta los mismos
ciudadanos luchan por contener la
inflación y mitigar lo que se vislumbra
como una profundísima crisis económica
pero más allá de eso hay quienes se
preguntan cuál es el costo de un funeral
de esta envergadura veamos se estima que
el funeral de la princesa diana costó
unos 10 millones de libras esterlinas en
1997 después del 2012 desde la madre de
la reina isabel valió unos 5 millones de
libras esterlinas sobre este nuevo
suceso como no hay cifras oficiales el
portal inside air que ha hecho un
seguimiento minucioso de los eventos
reales asegura que celebrar el evento
ceremonial en británico más grande desde
la década de 1950 implica que la
economía deja de recibir entre 1200
millones y 1600 millones de libras
esterlinas tal y como ocurrió después de
la boda real del príncipe william y kate
middleton en 2011 primero la corona lo
que va a heredar entonces que el rey
carlos tercero es la corona que ha sido
transferida a su hijo carlos y también
están los bienes personales de la reina
entre otras cosas que veremos a
continuación
así es daniela
la reina isabel deja su corona así como
una inmensa fortuna personal que incluye
numerosas propiedades
el castillo de balmoral en escocia está
valorado en 114 millones de euros la
casa de sandro en hama en inglaterra
vale 65 millones sus otros activos
incluyen prósperas tierras de cultivo un
amplio registro de acciones una
colección real de sellos obras de arte y
caballos de pura sangre
en total la fortuna de la reina se
estima en
436 millones de euros se espera que sus
hijos y nietos reciban su herencia pero
el reparto de sus bienes sigue siendo un
secreto ya que la familia real está
exenta de la ley que obliga a hacer
públicos los testamentos de los
ciudadanos británicos
salía donde la reina isabel tiene vía
libre ciertamente tuvo cuidado con su
testamento porque era una mujer que
había planeado las cosas durante mucho
tiempo e hizo algunas provisiones para
su familia y quizás también regalos para
los amigos y para aquellos que
trabajaron para ella durante mucho
tiempo como forma de agradecimiento
lo que es cierto es que el patrimonio de
la monarca que incluye las joyas de la
corona pasa directamente al siguiente en
la línea de sucesión en este caso el rey
carlos tercero como rey carlos también
hereda el ducado de lancaster que le
proporciona unos ingresos anuales de
aproximadamente 27 millones de euros y
por ley el monarca del reino unido está
exento de pagar el impuesto sobre el
patrimonio esto significa que el rey
carlos no tendrá que pagar el impuesto
de sucesiones del país que es del 40 por
ciento lo que ayuda a mantener intactas
las posesiones de la familia real
mientras tanto como nuevo príncipe de
gales william ha aireado el antiguo
título de su padre y el ducado de con
world lo que le significaría unos
ingresos anuales de aproximadamente 24
millones de euros
cambiamos daniela ahora de tema sí señor
a francia y rumanía firmaron un acuerdo
para ayudar a evacuar los granos 10 de
ucrania bueno todos sabemos que las
exportaciones de granos desde este país
se han desplomado desde el comienzo de
la guerra porque sus puertos del mar
negro que es una ruta clave para los
envíos fueron cerrados lo que elevó los
precios mundiales de los alimentos y
también generó temores de escasez en
áfrica y el medio oriente
rumanía es el segundo mayor exportador
de trigo de la unión europea a países no
pertenecientes a este bloque incluido
egipto y el mayor exportador de maíz así
que ha sido una de las rutas
alternativas utilizadas para exportar
estos cereales ucranianos ahora este
acuerdo consiste en que parís va a
invertir en mejorar la eficiencia en el
puerto rumano rumano de galati y otros
terminales portuarios
estas importaciones son vitales y
necesarias para que ucrania el cuarto
exportador de granos a nivel mundial
restablezca un recurso estratégico
esencial pero también para que los
países europeos continúen teniendo una
relación con ucrania y aún más para que
los países en desarrollo puedan
beneficiarse prioritariamente de esa
producción significativa y a menudo
vital danny y las grandes franquicias de
pago van a poner la lupa sobre las
ventas de armas esto en eeuu y como lo
van a hacer hasta el viernes las ventas
de tiendas de armas se consideraban
mercancía general pero la organización
internacional para la estandarización
aprobó la creación de un código
comercial específico para los minoristas
de arma avisa al procesador de pagos más
grande del mundo así como mastercard y
american express ya dijeron que lo
usarían y eso lo que hará es que
identificar las transacciones en las
tiendas de armas de fuego y detectar
cuando se incrementan de manera
sospechosa esto como un preludio de que
podría haber un tiroteo masivo algunos
activistas por los derechos de las armas
les preocupa que este nuevo código pueda
dar lugar a una vigilancia no autorizada
por ejemplo la asociación nacional del
rifle dijo que esta decisión de la
industria no es más que una concesión
ante los políticos y activistas
empeñados en erosionar los derechos de
los estadounidenses respetuosos de la
ley de todas maneras todos estos
tiroteos masivos y raúl han abierto otra
vez el debate sobre el control de armas
en eeuu lamentables estos tiroteos
masivos en ese en ese país gracias a mí
como siempre por toda la información
viajamos directo hasta parís